okay so let's now get into
the it's not even really a maya culpa
interview that ted cruz
gave to sean hannity on fox news because
he doesn't really say he did anything
wrong
other than saying i realized i i think
he says like as he was getting on the
plane to go to cancun convenient time to
realize it
that maybe the optics of the trip
weren't quite so good so
let's get into ted cruz's various
explanations for the misguided trip to
cancun last week again to reset the
story for you
texas gets hit with storms and cold
which causes power outages many
republicans try to blame frozen wind
farms for the power outages that's wrong
most of the problem with power with
electricity supply in texas was caused
by
frozen instruments at nuclear power
plants
at natural gas power plants and at coal
power plants yes some windmills froze
mostly the problem was the fossil fuels
and the nuclear
and of course the reason for this is not
because wind farms and nuclear and coal
and gas
can't produce power in cold weather
it's because texas even though a decade
ago
had a similar power outage and got a
report saying
here's how you winterize all of these
types of power generation
they didn't do it so that's why this is
going on
okay so um here are ted cruz's
explanations for why in the midst of all
this
he decided to go to cancun and then come
back first
relatively early in the scandal ted
cruz's office put out a statement
basically throwing his own daughters
under the bus saying quote with school
cancelled for the week our girls
ask to take a trip with friends wanting
to be a good dad he just wants to be a
good dad
everybody with wanting to be a good dad
i flew down with them last night and i'm
flying back this afternoon
now unfortunately the decision to fly
back
quote this afternoon was not the
originally scheduled
trip of ted cruz he changed his ticket
to fly back
immediately 20 hours after landing
because the story exploded
and we know that ted cruz went down
there with a bunch of luggage
we later learned he had a flight booked
not for friday but for the weekend so he
had to change his explanation once that
got out he had intended to stay
for several days uh cruz had the amount
of luggage i bring on a 10-day trip
and he wanted us to believe it was a
20-hour trip so that one imploded very
quickly
then ted cruz is interviewed at the
cancun airport
on his way back let's take a look at
that video so actually down with them
last night dropped them off here and now
i'm headed back to texas
and back to continuing to work to try to
get the power of what's happening in
texas is unacceptable that a lot of
texans are hurting
the valiant and brave public servant
heading back from a 20-hour trip
to get the power back on wait a second
it wasn't even a vacation he was
basically just chaperoning the flight
down and he was going to work remotely
okay
so then ted cruz upon returning to texas
agrees to do
the big interview with fox news
propagandist sean hannity to really
clear the air
and get back on the in the good graces
of the american people
it starts with sean hannity sucking up
to ted cruz so right after
we saw this we knew it wasn't going to
be a real interview and you were fully
and completely engaged and i know that
from my own reporting and my own
conversations with you and governor
abbott and with joe bastardi
so a priori before the interview
sean hannity already has cleared ted
cruz of wrongdoing
great for ted so then hannity keeps
doing it keeps it going
and says listen you can be a senator and
just make a quick round
trip to cancun i think you can be a
father
and be the senator of texas all at the
same time
and make a round-trip quick drop-off
trip and come home
well sean that's right and hannity uh
barely stopping short there of i would
be worried
if you weren't going to cancun in the
midst of this senator what a hero and
what a great father you are thank you so
much
okay so finally it's ted cruz's turn
and he goes into his explanation our
house was dark we had no heat
actually the fireplace behind me we were
all huddled around the fireplace
because it was the only heat in the
house and and after a couple of days
after the girls being really cold at
being in the teens
and the 20s outside our girl's ass said
look
school's been canceled for the week can
we take a trip
and and go somewhere warm and and heidi
and i as parents we
we said okay sure and so last night i
flew down with them
uh to the beach uh and then i flew back
this afternoon i'd initially planned to
stay through the weekend and to work
remotely there but but as i
as i was heading down there you know i
started to have second thoughts
almost immediately so notice there that
ted cruz
because he was outed as having a return
a round-trip ticket where he wasn't
coming back until the weekend
he had to say i initially planned to
stay through the weekend which is true
but he realized he really should be in
texas by which he means i got caught
the blaming of the daughters is
hilarious too and i was thinking
like what kid demands to go on vacation
the next day to mexico
and gets the okay from their parents
like growing up for me
and all of my friends vacations and
trips were planned in advance
hey mom and dad let's go to cancun
tomorrow like in 12 hours
sure let's do it i'm just trying to be a
good dad
this was simply escaping a bad situation
in the united states and fleeing across
the u.s mexico border
that way south for a better situation in
cancun that's all that this was
and then one last clip which is really
funny in continuing
to explain the cancun trip ted cruz
casually mentions that a lot of his
daughter's friends were over for dinner
there's a pandemic going on what are you
doing having multiple kids over from
multiple households
tonight we had a bunch of kids at our
house because our house was one of the
few houses that had power and so we had
a lot of our daughter's friends were
over we're making dinner for them
and right about i don't know 6 6 30 boom
the lights go out and we lose power
and so we had a candlelight dinner
because that's all we had we had
flashlights and then the girls all
camped out they got in sleeping bags and
wrapped up in
in uh in comforters and everything and
then we flew to cancun
and it was all great sean truly truly
great so
a big explanation from ted cruz that
quite frankly explained
nothing other than what we thought which
is ted cruz continues to live in his own
world
and when the outside world got into his
life he lost power
he decided to flee across the border to
the country of mexico
he should resign there are many calls
for his resignation
he's not going to resign we'll have more
coverage of this
on our instagram at david pakman show
by the way if you want to see what
happened to my hair
thanks to the wind over the weekend
follow me on instagram at david
pakman it's bizarre and it's probably
not something you want to let children
see it's really a uh
it's it's a um it's a hair disaster for
lack of a better term quick break back
after this
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david